OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON WE WILL
BEGIN THE.
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO ON EDUCATION FINANCE
TODAY'S HOT HEARING IS THE
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWO TEEN TWENTY NINETEEN.
BUDGET RELATES TO PROP NINETY
EIGHT IN K. TWELVE.
I WITH THAT PLEASE THAT CALL THE
ROLL.
MCCARTY HERE*
LONG MEDINA YOUR CLASSIC
AIR O'DONNELL.
YEAH OKAY.
SO WITH THAT THAT TODAY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM OUR. OUR
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TORE LOOKS IN
HIS IN HIS FAT EIGHT YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT THINGS FOR OUR
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA AND HIS
LAST CHANCE COMING BEFORE US TO
GIVE THE STATE OF EDUCATION BUT
I KNOW HE'S GOING TO BE WORKING
TILL THE VERY END.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LA JOH. AS WELL AS I
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE START THIS
YEAR'S PROCEEDINGS LOOKING AT
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT. BUDGET I
WILL SAY THAT FOR THE LAST.
FOR FIVE WEEKS I PROBABLY HAD
ABOUT TWENTY MEETINGS IN MY
OFFICE ABOUT THE BUDGET AND THE
BUZZ IS. ALL THE MONEY WENT TO
THEIR RAINY DAY AND TO THE
SCHOOL SO PAN. AYE THAT'S A GOOD
THING FOR PROP NINETY EIGHT OF
COURSE FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS IN
OUR COMMUNICATIVE IS.
BUT I WILL SAY A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK THAT. WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE
HERE IN K. TWELVE BUT I ALSO
NOTE THAT WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO YOU KNOW WE STILL WE'RE
STILL.
YOU KNOW IN THE BOTTOM FOUR
FORTIES IN PER PUPIL FUNDING.
THEY WERE JUST THAT COMING OUT
THE GREAT RECESSION AS WELL AS
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE ALL KINDS OF.
NEEDS A NEED TO ADDRESS AND SO
WILL BE GETTING IN THAT THIS
YEAR I CERTAINLY THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS A
GOOD STARTING POINT. A FULLY
FUNDING OUR LOCAL CONTROL A
FUNDING FORMULA REACHING THE
TARGET TWO YEARS EARLIER THAN
EXPECTED. PROVIDING ONGOING
FUNDING FROM OUR FOR OUR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE A. NEW CAT JOINT
HEARING RIGHT NOW.
A CONCURRENT WITH THIS HEARINGS
TO SOME OF THE MEMBERS ARE OVER
THERE. CAN MAKE BECOMING A BIT
LATER AND SO I CERTAINLY WERE
PLEASES FAR AS THE FUNDING LEVEL
WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WERE NOT
A BELONGS IN. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OR INDICATE TWELVE A
SCHOOL SYSTEM TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
WE'VE SEEN SOME.
IMPROVEMENTS. IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS THROUGH FOR EARLY
EDUCATION WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THAT. GOING FORWARD AND THIS
BUDGET ALSO CONTAINS THEM. I
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES TO
INCREASE.
THE EL CAP OVERSIGHT WHICH IS
CERTAINLY A GOOD THING BY NO
THERE ARE MORE.
IDEAS AS WELL.
I KNOW WE HAVE. SOME ON GOING
QUESTIONS ON SOME LARGER ISSUES
BUT THIS IS OF COURSE THE
BEGINNING OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND WITH THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO.
HAVE BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING ANY
OPENING COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT HEARING
NONE SO FIRST WE LIKE TO BRING
UP. AS USUAL OUR SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION FOR CITY
CALIFORNIA A TOM TOWARDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS.
GLAD TO BE HERE THIS IS A GOOD
BUDGET WE CAN SAY A GREAT BUDGET
AND IT'S SO GREAT TO BE HERE TO
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE IN FRONT
OF US TO. INVEST FURTHER IN
MAJOR SIGNIFICANT WAYS IN
EDUCATION AND SUPPORTING ALL OF
OUR CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
STUDENTS.
IT'S GREAT TO BE BEFORE YOU AS
WE TALK ABOUT MAKING CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS IN OUR SCHOOLS.
I REMEMBER ALL TOO WELL THE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS WE HAD A
FEW YEARS AGO AND YOU REMEMBER
THEM AS WELL. TERRIBLE TIMES IN
TERMS OF CUTBACKS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SCHOOL DISTRICT LEVEL.
COUNTIES AS WELL AS IN OUR
DEPARTMENT IN SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
AS YOU MAY RECALL I IN MY FIRST
YEAR IN OFFICE DECLARED A STATE
OF FISCAL EMERGENCY.
YEAH WE HAD ALREADY. SEEN THE
LAYOFF OF THIRTY THOUSAND
TEACHERS WERE THREATENED WITH
ANOTHER TEN TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
TEACHERS BEING LAID OFF WE. SAW
TWENTY THOUSAND CLASSIFIED
TEACHERS.
DO CLASSIFIED STAFF ALSO.
LAID OFF AND A LOT OF PROGRAM'S
DISMANTLED IN ARTS MUSIC AND.
DRAMA AND CIVICS AND SCIENCE
AND SO.
WHERE IT'S IN SUCH A MUCH
BETTER TIME?
AND WE MADE MUCH PROGRESS IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. THAT I'M EXCITED
TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY.
AND AS THE CHAIRMAN UNDERSCORED
AS PROGRESS.
BUT ALSO ROAD MAP MUCH MORE THAT
WE NEED TO DO TO ADDRESS.
COMPREHENSIVELY THE NEEDS OF ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS.
MOST RECENTLY.
AS NEW STATE POLL SHOWS GREAT
GROWING SUPPORT FOR THE STATE IN
A RECENTLY LAUNCHED.
SCHOOL REPORT CARD.
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
IS RECEIVING FIND REVIEWS FROM
THE PUBLIC ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF
THOSE SURVEYED SIXTY ONE PERCENT
LIKE THE INFORMATION THE
DASHBOARD GIVES.
AND FELT IT WAS EASY TO USE. WE
ALWAYS THOUGHT FOCUSING ON
MULTIPLE MEASURES IS A BETTER
THAN FOCUS IN A ONE ONE OR TWO
NUMBERS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY A RECENT REPORT
FROM THE LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE FOUND THAT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
FROM LC FF HAVE LED TO
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATE. AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
PARTICULARLY AMONG CHILDREN FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
THE NEED.
ISRAEL NOT ONLY TO MAINTAIN
CURRENT PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT.
BUT WITH ALSO. DO MORE TO MEET
ALL THE NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE READY FOR COLLEGE AND
CAREER.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. ONGOING IN THESE
EFFORTS.
I AM PLEASED THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
NEAR SU CHI HAS INTRODUCED A
BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY.
THAT THE SENATE HAS A PROPOSAL
AS WELL BUT IT ADDRESSING. THESE
NEEDS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO LOOK AT HOW
WE CONTINUE TO INCREASE ENSURING
FUNDING FOR LCF F. NOW THAT WE
ARE NO LONGER IN TRANSITION.
CD FUNDING YOU JUST CAME IN YOU
MENTIONED.
TREAT THE OTHER HEARING THIS.
WORKING ON THIS DAY. I KNOW THAT
YOU JUST CAME FROM THAT HEARING
AND LOOKING AT THE FUTURE IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY FUTURE. OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION. SO I
WILL ONLY ADD A FEW POINTS TO
AND WHAT YOU HEARD IF YOU WERE
IN THE PREVIOUS HEARING AND AND.
GO BEYOND WHAT OF OUR CHAIRMAN.
MCCARTY HAS SAID I APPRECIATE
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR C. TO EAT MORE
HOWEVER NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
ENSURE. THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
THE EDUCATION TRAINING. AND
SKILLS OUR YOUTH NEED.
EXCEED.
UNDER THE SEEDIER SIDE OF GRANT
PROGRAMS SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO CREATE AND EXPAND CT
PROGRAMS.
DRIVEN BY CURRENT REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE LABOR MARKET DATA.
STUDENT INTEREST AND ALIGNMENT
WITH PROGRAMS OFFERED IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
I'M MOST INTERESTED IN HAVING AN
EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT ENABLES
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS TO GRADUATE.
FROM HIGH SCHOOL READY FOR
COLLEGE AND CAREER.
AND THAT WE PROVIDE AS MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ENGAGEMENT AND
EXPLORATION OF BOTH THE COLLEGE
AND CAREER SIDE OF THINGS.
WE DON'T WANT TO LIMIT CHOICES.
I DO BELIEVE THAT MORE FUNDING
IS NEEDED AND I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL IS TAKING.
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
CD FUNDING AND DEVELOP MORE
PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS.
AND THAT WOULD BE A BILL AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE WOULD
PROVIDE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION A
YEAR FOR THREE YEARS. AS.
CD PROGRAMS.
NEED THAT FURTHER INVESTMENT.
STATEWIDE SYSTEM A SUPPORT IS
ANOTHER TOPIC I'M PLEASED TO SEE
THE GOVERNOR PROVIDING SEVENTY
MILLION IN THE STATE FUNDS FOR
THIS SYSTEM.
INCLUDING FIFTY FIVE MILLION TO
HELP COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
WORK WITH SCHOOL DISTRICT.
TO IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES
USING THE DATA FROM THE
DASHBOARD TO GUIDE POLICIES
AND ACTION.
WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
EDUCATION PARTNERS AT THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. THE CT
THIS CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE OF
EDUCATION EXCELLENCE AND SAY
CESA IN THE STATE WAS. AGENCIES
GROUP TO WORK TOGETHER ALIGNED
IT AWAY AS I'VE SEEN AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED WAVE COOPERATION
BETWEEN THESE MAJOR COMPONENTS
OF OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AGENCIES GROUP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SYSTEM IS ALIGNED WITH WHAT
WILL TRULY HELP CREATE
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT.
WE KNOW THERE IS MORE THAT WE
CAN DO TO BETTER ALIGN SERVICES
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO. FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS COMMITTEE ON
HOW WE CAN USE FEDERAL FUNDING.
TO BUILD ON THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT.
SPECIAL EDUCATION I KNOW IT'S A
TOPIC WE'RE ALL. DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
WAS AGAIN VERY PLEASE TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR SUPPORT FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT. OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS JUST ONE AREA
IMPACTED BY THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE.
AND I'M LOOKING TO THE STATE
DIVIDE MORE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THOSE OTHER AREAS SUCH AS STEM
AND BILINGUAL EDUCATION.
NOW IN FACILITIES FACILITIES
BOND I'M GLAD TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR.
SAYING THAT HE WILL INCREASE
MORE BOND FUNDING. FOR SCHOOLS
WE KNOW HOW DESPERATELY SCHOOLS
NEED. TO REHABILITATE BUILDINGS
AND MODERNIZE BUILDINGS MAKE
THEM TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS.
I URGE YOU TO PROVIDE EVEN MORE
BOND FUNDING FOR DESPERATELY
NEEDED. WE HAVE AND
MODERNIZATION AND FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
AS I TRAVEL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE I SEE FIRSTHAND THE DIRE
NEEDS IN THIS AREA.
EARLY EDUCATION. WE KNOW EARLY
EDUCATION WORKS PROVIDING
EDUCATION AND CARE TO OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS IS ANOTHER
AREA.
THAT IS NICE TO BE FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING ACCESS TO QUALITY
SETTINGS FOR ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN.
BUT ESPECIALLY FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE.
I AM PLEASE AT THE GOVERNOR IS
MAINTAINING THE COMMITMENT TO
INCREASE RATES AND SLOTS.
I'LL CONCLUDE WITH A LOOK AT MY
VISION AND GOALS FOR THIS FINAL
YEAR IN THIS OFFICE.
I'M DEFINITELY NOT TAKEN A SLOW
WALK TO THE FINISH LINE SOME OF
YOU NO I LIKE TO JOG ON THAT.
TRACK RUNNER GUY.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO JUST KEEP
RUNNING OF FULL SPEED THERE LOTS
OF THINGS I STILL WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH. FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND
STUDENT AND I'M GOING TO BE
WORKING HARD TO ACCOMPLISH THEM
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS.
ON THE LEGISLATIVE FRONT I AM
GOING TO CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE%
FOR MORE RESOURCES FOR OUR
SCHOOLS INCLUDING INVESTMENTS IN
EARLY EDUCATION.
CT AND FACILITIES.
BEING FORTY FIFTH IN THE NATION
IS NOT. WHERE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE?
IN PER PUPIL SPENDING AND I
THINK YOU UNDERSCORE THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN IN YOUR OPENING REMARKS
WE WE DO NEED MORE FUNDING.
THERE IS ANOTHER AREA THAT HAS
BEEN A DRIVING FORCE THROUGHOUT
MY CAREER AS A TEACHER AND
COACH.
A LEGISLATOR IN SUPERINTENDENT
AND THAT IS STUDENT SAFETY AND
HEALTH.
TWO YEARS AGO I CONVENE A
STATEWIDE.
SCHOOL SAFETY COMMITTEE TO LOOK
AT WAYS WE CAN BETTER PARTNER
WITH OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE.
THERE ARE SCHOOLS ARE TAKEN THE
STEPS NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS.
THE TERRIBLE TRAGEDIES IN
FLORIDA INNER. AND IN OUR OWN
SANDRA DINO SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES SHOWS NOW MORE THAN
EVER THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE.
THAT PLANNING.
AND PREPARED BICU PLANNING AND
PREPARED FOR WHATEVER EMERGENCY
MIGHT OCCUR.
WELL DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO STOP IT FROM HAPPENING.
IMPORTANTLY AS WE ALSO NEED TO
ENSURE WE ARE ADDRESSING THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
STUDENTS. FROM PHYSICAL HEALTH
AND ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS FOODS
AND HEALTH CARE.
AND NEVER BEFORE MORE IMPORTANT
NOW MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT.
IT IS IMPERATIVE.
THAT WE PROVIDE MORE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS HAS COME UP
MORE AND MORE OVER AND OVER.
FREQUENTLY WHERE EVER I MEET
WITH EDUCATORS.
EDUCATION. ADMINISTRATIVE
LEADERS.
AND PARENT GROUPS AND
IMPORTANTLY.
WHEN I TALK WITH STUDENTS.
IN RECENT MONTHS IT HAS COME UP
IN JUST ABOUT EVERY SETTING I'VE
BEEN IN.
STUDENTS KNOW THEY NEED MORE
SUPPORT TO HELP THEM COPE AND
MANAGE THE DAILY STRESSES OF
THEIR LIVES.
BUT ALSO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS.
ARE COMING TO SCHOOL WHILE
DEALING WITH SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA.
THEY SEE THE NEED.
FOR THEMSELVES
AND FOR THEIR PEERS.
TEACHERS AND STAFF SEE IT TOO
AND THEY ARE DESPERATE FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND TOOLS
TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS
AND TO BETTER IDENTIFY WHEN
STUDENTS NEED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
PARENTS ALSO PUT SAFETY AND
SCHOOL CLIMATE AT THE VERY TOP
OF THEIR PRIORITIES.
SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT SAID IN IT.
THAT IT WAS THE TOP PRIORITY
INTERNET SOURCE SURVEY FROM LAST
FALL.
THE WORLD IS A MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT PLACE FOR YOUTH TODAY.
THEY'RE FACING CHALLENGES AND
ISSUES.
BUT I CERTAINLY NEVER IMAGINED.
NOR DID THE PREVIOUS GENERATION.
I AM HOPING.
THAT WE'RE WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
RESOURCES AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVELS.
AND AT THE STATE LOCAL LEVELS
I'M HOPING TO GET MORE FUNDING
TO ENSURE THAT MY STAFF AT THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION ARE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS
AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO STAFF
AND STUDENTS.
RELATEDLY KNOW THAT THE SCHOOL
CULTURE AND SCHOOL CLIMATE IS
IMPORTANT EVERYONE SAFE SCHOOLS
MATTER. AND IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
STUDENTS FEEL CONNECTED TO THEIR
SCHOOLS.
I AM GRATEFUL TO THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR HIS
AUTHORSHIP.
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THAT
WILL PROVIDE SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS WITH TOOLS TO BETTER
ADDRESS THE OVERALL SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
OUR VIEWS AND OUR GOALS.
THIS AFTERNOON I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS WE MOVE TO
ENSURE RESOURCES FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE AVAILABLE.
WITH THAT GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND.
I APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
YOU DO. IN THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK U. SUPERINTENDENT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND I KNOW
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
ALTHOUGH ITALIA.
I NEXT LET'S BRING UP THE.
PANEL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OAK
BEFORE IT BEFORE YOU LEAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR OUR
SUPERINTENDENT.
YES MISTER MARTZ EGYPT WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
AS YOUR LAST A.
OPENING A ADDRESS TO OUR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AS
OUR STATE SUPERINTENDENT WANTED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
YOUR MANY YEARS OF.
OF BEING A CHAMPION FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
.
I WANTED TWO WERE. HAVING SAID
THAT. YOU KNOW.
I I FEEL THAT I'M I'M FACING A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE WITH THE
WHAT I'M WORKING ON WITH.
MANY OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
STAKEHOLDERS.
HERE AND SACRAMENTO IN TRYING TO
LOOK BEYOND. OF THE FOR FUNDING
THE PROPOSED FULL FUNDING OF.
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
HOW DO WE GET FROM?
JUST GETTING BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT TWO FULL AND FAIR
FUNDING FOR ALL SCHOOL.
DISTRICTS AND AND I REALIZE BOTH
FROM AT THE CHAIRS OPENING
REMARKS AS WELL AS YOUR OPENING
REMARKS.
THAT.
I AM FIGHTING AGAINST THE THE
THE PREVAILING NARRATIVE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT THIS IS A GOOD
BUDGET.
FOUR K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION WHEN IN FACT YOU KNOW
WE.
THERE WE ARE.
DEALING WITH DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE BETTER TALKING ABOUT.
ABOUT THEM.
PROJECTIONS OF DEFICIT SAY YEAR
OUT OR TWO YEARS OUT.
WITH THE.
.
RAPIDLY RISING COSTS.
NOW WHETHER IT'S SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS ARE PENSION
COSTS OR.
.
NO. HEALTH CARE COSTS THAT ALL
ALL THE COSTS THAT.
THAT EVERYONE IN THE REAL WORLD
HAS TO FACE THAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE NARRATIVE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN WHAT THE
OUR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
ARE ARE ARE TELLING US.
AS AS WE WELL.
MOVED BEYOND THE.
PROPOSED.
FULL FUNDING OF THE LOCA DRAW
FUNDING FORMULA. OF THIS US ONE
POINT THE SECOND POINT IS YOU
KNOW I I FEEL THAT.
NOT ONLY DO WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THE FULL AND ADEQUATE
FUNDING OF OF ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT. THE NEED
FOR FOR GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN
TERMS OF HOW THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FOR.
FORMALLY DOLLARS
PACIFIC LEE THE THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE.
.
THE US MUST BE ALLOCATED FOR OUR
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS YOU KNOW
HOW EXACTLY THAT THAT IS TO BE
SPENT AND SO.
.
MISTER SUPERINTENDENT WANT TO
ASK YOU FIRST WITH ON THAT POINT
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE INCREASING
GUY GRADUATION RATES.
AND AND THE.
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT WE ARE
RECEIVING SEEING AND AND OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
BUT.
.
WITHOUT DATA AS TO HOW THE
SUPPLEMENT ON CONCENTRATION
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT HOW'RE
YOU ABLE TO ATTRIBUTE.
.
THOSE.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS TO.
WOULD BE.
LOW CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THANK YOU.
SIMILAR FOR THOSE QUESTIONS OF
THOSE COMMENTS THIS IS THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT THAT I
DESCRIBED. IS ONE WAY WE'RE
GETTING THE DATA ANALYZING THE
DATA DISK
SCHOOLS ARE SHARING DATA AS
HEARING STRATEGIES BEST
PRACTICES.
I IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS ARE GIVEN THE THE
OPPORTUNITIES.
IT IS A CHALLENGE AND WEAK
CONTINUALLY WORK FOR THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND FOR DISTRICTS
TO SHARE. AND I IN ALL MY YEARS
IN EDUCATION AS LONG NUMBER OF.
THOSE YEARS I I DON'T THINK
I'VE SEEN THIS LEVEL OF
COOPERATION EVER BEFORE. AND
THROUGH THE. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATION EXCELLENCE WE HAVE
MANY PILOT PROGRAMS GOING ON WE
HAVE MANY. HELPING PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING GROUPS GOING ON AND.
THEY'RE HELPING EACH OTHER WITH
PEER SUPPORT AND AGAIN BEST
PRACTICES
SO IT'S IT'S CRITICAL TO.
I MAINTAIN THE PUBLIC'S.
SUPPORT AND TRANSPARENCY IS PART
OF THAT. THE PUBLIC IN GENERAL
HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF OUR
SCHOOLS OF A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE.
THE BOND MEASURES LOCALS
DISTRICTS PUTTING FOR OTHER
VOTERS IN THE LAST ELECTIONS AND
NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF THOSE
PASSED.
AND OF COURSE THEY PASSED THE
PROP FIFTY ONE AND.
AND PROP FIFTY FIVE.
I BUT IT'S CRITICAL THEY
TRANSPARENCY YOU SPOKE OF AND
FINALLY.
ON YOUR POINT ABOUT THE LEVEL
OF FUNDING. ADD TO BE FORTY FOUR
TO FORTY FIFTH IN THE NATION IS
NOTHING TO BRAG ABOUT. THAT WE
NEED TO AIM FOR THE TOP GET
RIGHT BACK TO THE TOP OR
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN IN THE PAST
IN INVESTING IN OUR KIDS IN PER
PUPIL SPENDING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA.
ALSO WANNA THANK AS
SUPERINTENDENT FOR ALL HIS YEARS
OF SERVICE.
I I REMEMBER WELL AND AND
FINALLY YOUR VISIT TO.
RIVERSIDE TO.
OUT TWICE RIGHT RIVERSIDE POLY
FOR THE DEAF. AS WELL BOTH AND
RIVERSIDE.
SO WHEN I SAY THANK YOU.
.
YEAH FORTY FOUR FORTY FIFTH IS
NO PLACE TO BE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
GET.
THE EDUCATION THEY DESERVE.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO. THE YEAR
AHEAD WORKING WITH THE WITH YOU
IN THE DEPARTMENT ON A.
DIFFERENT LEGISLATION AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
THEY PUT ME JUST ASK YOU ONE
QUESTION I JUST ASKED OVER AT
THE CT  HEARING. YES SO.
THERE IS THAT THE GOOD NEWS IS
WE HAVE MONEY ON THE TABLE AND
IT WAS THAT YEAR TO YEAR TO SING
IT WAS GONNA EXISTENCE SO.
GRANTED TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE.
MAY NOT BE THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT MAYBE WE CAN GO NORTH
WILL LOOK AT THAT.
BUT THERE IS SOME CONCERN AS FAR
AS WHETHER IT'S DOWN THROUGH THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST IS THERE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF BAD.
OUT WHAT ONE THING THAT I I'D
BEEN CONTINUALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THAT.
IT WILL WHOEVER OVERSEAS IT IT
IF YOU KNOW THERE'S A THOUSAND
HIGH SCHOOLS ARE SAU IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IF YOU'RE.
YEAH IF YOU'RE IN A HIGH SCHOOL
IF YOU'RE IN A HIGH SCHOOL
VARSITY IF YOU'RE IN A HIGH
SCHOOL IT'S IN THE CONSORTIUM
THAT SCORES WELL DID YOU DO
WELL.
IN THE OLD DAYS OF THE
CATEGORICAL EVERY SCHOOL GOT A
LITTLE BIT OF MONEY SO IF YOU'RE
A KID AT SCHOOL YOU YOU COULD
CONCEIVABLY GET SOMETHING SO.
ARE YOU CONCERNED AT ALL THAT IF
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HELP
EVERY THAT'S EQUALITY.
AND THAT EVERYBODY HAS A CHANCE
TO PARTICIPATE IF THEY WANTED TO
GO CUT IN ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO YOU KNOW
FLIP A COIN TO SEE IF THEY'RE IN
THE RIGHT HIGH SCHOOLER MOVE
ACROSS TOWN OR.
DO YOU KNOW IN OUR DISTRICT
TRANSFER WHAT HAVE YOU.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
LEVEL OF SUPPORT IT EVERY
SINGLE.
NIGHT SIGHTS EVERY KID CAN CAN
PARTICIPATE IF HERE SHE WANTS
TO.
THAT'S THE GOAL THAT THE THE
BEST FORM OF THAT GOAL. AND IT
EFFORT NEEDS TO BE TO KEEP
FIGHTING THOSE WAYS WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE. CLOSE THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP AND INCREASE
THEIR OVERALL SUCCESS SO.
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
EFFORT THAT'S GOING ON THE
COLLABORATIVE WORK THE TEAMWORK.
DE AGAIN IT'S UNPRECEDENTED FROM
WHAT I'VE EVER SEEN IN THE PAST
IS NO PANACEA BUT IT IS. THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO I DO THINK WE
NEED TO. RAISE THE BASE ND HAVE
ALL VOTES RISE AND.
THAT WILL I THINK HELP.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AROUND THE
STATE AYE I'VE TRAVELED A LOT
AND TALK FREQUENTLY VISIT
FREQUENTLY WITH THE.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SUPERINTENDENTS AND TEACHERS UP
IN THE MOUNTAINS IN THE THE CASE
THE COUNTY FOR THEY HAVE ONE
SCHOOL FOR THE WHOLE COUNTY AND.
TAKES A A BUS A.
FLEET TO TRAVEL EVERY DAY AND
MOVE THE STUDENTS. FROM MARIPOSA
COUNTY THEY TRAVEL. FROM HERE TO
AKRON OHIO.
EQUIPMENT MILES DRIVE DRIVING
EVERY DAY TO GET THERE STUDENTS
TO SCHOOL SO MANY OF THESE YOUTH
BY CIRCUMSTANCES. ARE GETTING IS
FULL OF ACCESS IS I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT WE'RE WORKING OUT A
REACHING OUT AND WORKING WITH
THEM TO. SHARE BETTER ACCESS.
THANK YOU THAT LET'S BRING UP
NOW OUR PANEL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ELLIOT AND CD
OKAY START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA RESENTS GET
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
HANDOUT THAT YOU WILL RECEIVE
IT'S A TWO PAGE DOCUMENT WILL
KIND OF OUTLINE.
MY PRESENTATION SO A FIRST OF
ALL I WILL GO OVER THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
LEVELS FOR THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THAT ARE THAT HE HOBBIES OUT
HERE IS THE CUP THIS IS THAT YOU
HAVE A CHART THAT EVERYONE WANTS
THE FINANCE CHARGE ONCE A YEAR I
SURE APPRECIATE YOU. SAYING THAT
YES.
YEAH.
SO IF I MAY OUT WILL START IF
YOU'RE ONE WHICH IS THE OF THE
CHARTS SO I WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT OUT
FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND
WILL COVER SOME OF THE MAJOR
SPENDING PROPOSALS I'M OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S OTHER PROPOSALS AND WE
DO HAVE. COLLEAGUES IN STAFFORD
THERE WILL BE MORE THAN WILLING
TO ANSWER ANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS
BEYOND WHAT I OFFER.
SO THE FIRST CHARGES GIVES YOU A
HISTORICAL FUNDING TREND
ANALYSIS OF A WHERE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT HAS BEEN OVER THE
YEARS. AND THOSE OF THE BLUE
BARS IN ADDITION THAT PINK LINE
SHOWED YOU WERE REVENUES ARE SO
YOU CAN SEE THAT FOR THE MOST
PART OF HISTORICALLY THROUGH THE
YEARS PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
HAS
HISTORICALLY TRACKED WITH
INCREASES AND DECREASES WITH IT
WITH REVENUES.
I'M I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT OF THE
MAJOR DROPPED THE YOU SEE AN
ELEVEN TWELVE WHICH IS LIKE THE
END OF THE THE RECESSION.
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WAS
SENT FUNDED AT FORTY SEVEN POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS ON AND THE
PER PUPIL SPENDING ON ELEVEN
TWELVE WAS THAT SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
UP.
FROM THE LOW POINT ELEVEN TWELVE
ON THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE GROW
SUBSTANTIALLY PRIMARILY AGAIN TO
THIS INCREASE IN REVENUES.
AND WHERE WE ENDED UP TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS AT
SEVENTY EIGHT POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. AND THE PER
PEOPLE SPENDING IS ELEVEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS SO
THAT THE FORTY SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR INCREASE IN THAT TIME
PERIOD.
SO IN FIGURE TWO OF THIS JUST
SHOWS YOU THE THREE YEAR WINDOW
OF PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT DOT
GUARANTEE THAT'S IN THIS BUDGET.
OF THE FIRST AGAIN WERE SEEN
INCREASES IN A. GENERAL FUND
REVENUES COME IN ADDITION WERE
SEEN SOME NOTABLE INCREASES IN
PROPERTY TAX.
IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE WITHOUT
REMAINS UNCHANGED FROM OUR
PREVIOUS ESTIMATE. AND IT
REVENUES DROP JUST SLIGHTLY BUT
THE MOOD OF THE THE BIGGER
PICTURE REALLY IS AN INCREASE IN
REVENUES. ARE THESE REVENUES RE
UP PROPERTY TAX REVENUES REFLECT
THE COUNTY OTHER CONTROLLERS
REPORTED AMOUNTS.
AND WHAT WE FOUND WAS THE
ASSESSED VALUES A PROPERTIES
CAME A LOT HIGHER THAN OUR
ORIGINAL ESTIMATE.
NOT THAT INCREASE CARRIES
THROUGH TO ALL THREE YEARS AND
SO WE SEE THE BENEFIT OFFSETTING
THE GENERAL FUND FOR ALL THREE
OF OUR ESTIMATE YEARS.
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OF THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE I CAN WAS
PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
REVENUES A MINIMUM GUARANTEE
ENDS AT SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION IN THIS CURRENT
ESTIMATE WHICH IS SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION HIGHER THAN
OUR LAST FORECAST.
AND FINALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN RECEIVED A
GENERAL FUND REVENUES ABOUT
THIRTY FOUR POINT SIX BILLION.
ON THAT'S NEARLY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN OUR REVISED
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ESTIMATE AND
AS A RESULT AGAIN THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IS ESTIMATED TO BE
THREE POINT ONE BILLION MORE
THAN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REVISED.
AND WE LANDED THE SEVENTY EIGHT
POINT THREE BILLION THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AWARE
NOT CHANGING TESTS FOR
CONTINUING TO BE ON THE TEST
THREE YEAR HOWEVER WE ARE VERY
CLOSE TO MOVING INTO THE HAS TWO
WHICH JUST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WILL WILL BE IN A
TEST TO YEAR.
SO I'M AND I AND I MENTION THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER THING
THAT I WOULD KINDA LIKE TO NOTE.
IN THIS PROCESS AS WE MOVE
TOWARD ME REVISION ANY INCREASES
IN GENERAL FUND REVENUE WILL NOT
IMPACT THE GUARANTEE THAT YOU'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST.
A BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE FACTORS
SIR ARE SET UP THE MAJORITY OF
THE INCREASE THE REVENUE IT'S
GONNA BE LIMITED TO THE BALANCE
OF WHAT IS ON THE MAIN ITS
FACTOR BALANCE.
SO THAT'S ABOUT TO TURN TWENTY
MILLION AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND ABOUT THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION.
AND I EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO THERE
ARE A FEW OTHER FACTORS THAT CAN
CHANGE HOW WE DON'T. ANTICIPATE
THEM INTO CHANGING TOO MUCH BUT
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING TURNOUT
AND AND I KNOW THE LOT OF
REPORTS ABOUT THE RECENT RECENT
REVENUE FORECAST JUST SO YOU
KNOW IN EDUCATION. THERE MAY NOT
BE A BENEFITS THAT.
THE NO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S PER
HOW YOU'D SCORE IT. VERSES IN
NINETY EIGHT BUT.
WHAT IT DOES DAHLE BE?
?
MORE ONGOING THAN ONE TIME
PERCHED TOO LATE EARLY TELL
THEIR AT MINIMUM GUARANTEE WOULD
NOT WILL NOT INCREASE VERY MUCH
AT ALL SO TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
APPROPRIATE FUNDS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE. AND AND YOU KNOW NOT
CALCULATED THE MEN AND GUARANTEE
YOU CHRIS MOVE THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED BAR UP THE FOLLOWING
YEAR BUT. NO WE REALLY I'M AND I
BELIEVE THE LA AGREES ON THIS
POINT WITH ARE FACTORS THAT.
INCREASE IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
PROBABLY MAXES OUT AROUND TWO
TWENTY AND AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND A THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
REGARDLESS OF IF THE REVENUES GO
UP SIX BILLION IT'LL.
THAT WILL BE THE INCREASE.
SO THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BUDGET
MIGHT BENEFIT RETURN MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT.
THEY WERE GETTING A OF THIS
FUNDING OKAY I'M SO UP. ON THE
SECOND PAGE ON IS WHERE I GIVE
YOU A PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
DETAILS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
FIGURES THREE I JUST SUMMARIZES
THE VALUABLE FUNDING SOURCES OF
THE FIRST YEAR THEY AND CHANGES
IN THE GUARANTEE THAT I HAD
HIGHLIGHTED ON THE OTHER PAGE.
ON THEN ADDITION I'M IN A PROP
NINETY EIGHT WE HAVE ONE TIME
RESOURCES THAT BECOME AVAILABLE
I'M WHEN WE SPEND ONE TIME
MONEY.
SOME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SAVINGS ALSO ON THOSE TOTAL
ABOUT SIXTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN TOTAL AVAILABLE RESOURCES.
AND THEN IN ADDITION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A ONE
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR. A
SETTLER. PAYMENT OF THIS IS A
PROP TO DEBT PAYMENTS AND IT'S
WE'VE PAID IT TOWARDS THE SUBTLE
AB OUTSTANDING SETTLER.
SO IN FIGURE FOUR.
THERE'S THE DETAILED LIST OF
THE SPENDING IN THE GOVERNORS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
FIRST PART IS THE KEY TWELVE
EXPENDITURES. ARE IN THE
SPENDING PLAN IN THE SECOND PART
IS COMMUNITY COLLEGES I DON'T
PLAN ON GOING OVER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AGAIN SINCE YOU WENT
OVER YESTERDAY AND OVERHEARING.
I'M IN THE ONE TIME SPENDING FOR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
AGAIN WE WE WE TRY TO TAKE A
BALANCED APPROACH WITH THE ONE
TIME AN ON GOING THE LARGEST ONE
TIME AGAIN ISN'T DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING. OF THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS AGAIN WOULD GO
OUT TO ALL THE LIAISON AT EIGHTY
A BASIS. ARM AND TO THE EXTENT
THEY HAVE OUTSTANDING MANDATE.
ADAM BALANCES THE IT WOULD BE
APPLIED TOWARDS AS OUTSTANDING
BALANCES.
STATE THE NEXT TO.
.
BUT THAT SUPERINTENDENT ACTUALLY
DID A VERY GOOD JOB OF
DISCUSSING THESE PROPOSALS BUT
HE NEXT TO RELATED TO A SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROPOSAL. AS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE WHEN THE DASHBOARD
RELEASED IN THE FALL OF ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT BECAME
HIGHLIGHTED WAS THAT OF THE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT DISTRICTS.
I IDENTIFIED FOR DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE UMPS SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OR TWO THIRDS WERE
IDENTIFIED AS WERE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
SO AS PART OF THIS PLAN WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE PICKED A COUPLE
PROPOSALS IN ORDER TO KIND OF.
HOW IMPROVE SOME OF THOSE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES?
SO THE FIRST ONE IS A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION KINDA
TARGETED AND.
EARLY INTERVENTION AND THESE
ARE COMPETITIVE GRANTS THAT
WOULD GO OUT.
.
TO UP TO.
SPANS THE.
INCLUSIVE EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS
FROM ZERO TO FIVE POPULATION.
THE OTHER IS A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S TO TEACHER ARE
GRANTS BOTH COMPETITIVE GRANTS
ONE IS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND
THE OTHERS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A LOCAL SOLUTIONS GRANT
PROGRAM.
UP FOR THE ONGOING SPENDING
AGAIN.
AS THE LEGISLATURE AND THE%
GOVERNOR HAVE PRIORITIZE IN THE
PAST
THE THE THE HIGHEST PRIORITY IT
IS FULLY IMPLEMENTING THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. WITH
FEE INCREASES MY GUARANTEE WE
ARE ABLE TO BUILD THAT INTO THE
PLAN IS A THREE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT.
AND IMPLEMENTS THE LCF OUT TWO
YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
TOTAL.
.
INVESTMENT AND LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS IS BEEN TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT BRINGS THE A TF
UP TO SIXTY POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S THE CURRENT.
AS AN.
ANOTHER ONE TIME INVEST OUR
ONGOING INVESTMENT WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER IN THE HEARING BEFORE IS
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
AND IN THIS PROGRAM THE
GOVERNOR'S I'M PLANNING TO.
UTILIZE THE EXISTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO SUPPORT K.
TWELVE PROGRAMS IT INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING TO
CREATE THE K. TWELVE COMPONENT
OF THE STRONG WORKFORCE.
AND AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE
MILLION IN ORDER TO BUILD TO
FUND LOCAL INDUSTRY EXPERTS WHO
WILL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ELLIOTT IS.
ADDITIONALLY I'M ON ON GOING AS
THE A INCREASED SUPPORT IN THE
STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT. I'M ON
FIFTH AND HAND OUT THAT HE GAVE
YOU'LL SEE AT SIXTY NINE POINT
TWO MILLION AND THERE'S A COUPLE
OTHER PIECES TO IT. BUT THAT
PEACE AND PARTICULARS THREE
COMPONENTS.
OUR ONE OF THEM IS FIFTY FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION FOR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO SUPPORT
AND EXPAND THEIR EXISTING
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO A LOT OF THESE
EFFORTS ARE ALREADY GOING ON
THIS WOULD EXPAND THOSE. ON FOR
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND ALSO
ALLOW THEM TO PROVIDE THOSE
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE THAT ARE IN
NEED OF DIFFERENTIATED ASSIST.
ON THE OTHER PART OF THAT
COMPONENTS ARE IS A FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR FOR COUNTY OFFICES
EDUCATION. AND IN TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
LOCAL AREA EXPERTS IN ORDER TO.
THESE WILL BE COMPETITIVE
GRANTS AND ESTABLISH REGIONAL
EXPERTS IN THESE AREAS DIFFERENT
AREAS THAT ARE NEEDED.
HOLD ON ONE SEC.
SO. I'M ALMOST FINISHED THINK.
ADDITIONALLY ON THE STATE'S
ISN'T AS PRECLUDES THE EFFORTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE THIS
PLANNING PROVIDE SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION ONGOING AND THEN
UTILIZES A SAVINGS AT THAT AT
THAT WAS FOUND IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET APPOINTMENTS FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION. ON.
ADD TO SUPPORT THE COLLABORATIVE
WORK WITH THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
OTHER ANOTHER. THE FOUR POINT
THE FORTY NINE POINT THREE
MILLION FOR PRESCHOOL IS SPEED
THE LAST.
.
PAYMENT I WANT IS A PAIN BUT
IT'S THE FOOD JUST REFLECTS THE
FINAL MULTI YEAR. UP PAYMENT IN
MULTI YEAR AGREEMENT.
AND SO.
.
AGAIN I'M NOT GOING TO COVER
CAMINO COLLEGES BUT.
ALL THE DETAILS ARE THERE SO IF
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
SOMETHING THAT I DIDN'T COVER
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO.
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LA OF.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KENNETH
COUPON WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
I PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
BECAUSE I WAS ONE OF THE
TRICKIER. PARTS OF THE BUDGET
BECAUSE THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE IS
REALLY A MOVING TARGET THE
FORMULAS DEPEND ON NEARLY A
DOZEN DIFFERENT INPUTS.
AND THOSE INPUTS CHANGE REALLY
WITH EVERY BUDGET UP TO IT.
ARE TURNING TO PAGE ONE OF OUR
HAND OUT I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION GIVE YOU A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE.
AS YOU HEARD THE KEY FACTOR IN
THE INCREASES IN THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GUARANTY IS OUR THE REVISED US
REVISED ESTIMATES. UPPER
DIVISION THIS TO GENERAL FUND
REVENUE.
I WANT OTHER KEEFE FACTOR WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT WAS KEY
TWELVE ATTENDANCE AT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND PREVIOUSLY
ESTIMATED A SMALL ATTENDANCE
INCREASE HEARD A DECLINE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. ARE
THEY NOW ESTIMATE A SMALL
INCREASE.
AND THAT'S. A REALLY SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE ON.
EVEN A MINOR ATTENDANCE INCREASE
IN ONE YEAR AYE TRIGGERS A HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION. AND THAT PROVISION
EFFECTIVELY CANCEL THE EFFECT OF
ATTENDANCE DECLINES DURING THE
FOLLOWING TWO YEARS
SO EVEN THOUGH ATTENDANCE IS
PROJECTED TO DECLINE THREE
TENTHS OF A PERCENT. OF A
PERCENT IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
SMALL INCREASE IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN COUNCILS THAT.
AFFECTING THE CALCULATION OF THE
GUARANTEE.
BOB I THINK YOU ALSO HEARD ABOUT
THE STATE'S MAINTENANCE FACTOR
OBLIGATION AS YOU NO MAINTENANCE
FACTOR IS REALLY THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT TO
MAKE CATCH UP PAYMENTS TO
SCHOOLS. A TO MAKE UP FOR
REDUCTIONS DURING TIGHTER FISCAL
TIMES I SIX YEARS AGO THAT
OBLIGATION STOOD AT RIGHT AROUND
TEN POINT SIX BILLION. SO
REDUCING IT NOW TO WITH GOING TO
TWENTY MILLION AT THE END OF
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN I THINK AS A
MARKER OF THE STATE'S A FISCAL
PROGRESS OVER THE PAST SIX
YEARS.
I JUMPING AHEAD TO PAGE THREE.
QUE TWELVE FUNDING UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS ELEVEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS PER STUDENT IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. THAT'S AN
INCREASE OF AROUND FOUR PERCENT
OVER THE REVISED TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN LEVEL.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WOULD
MARK THE SEVENTH CONSECUTIVE
YEAR OF INCREASES IN PER PUPIL
FUNDING. THAT IS TIED FOR THE
LONGEST STREAK SINCE THE
ADOPTION OF PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT TO NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
ARE TURNING TO PAGE FOUR OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BUDGET
I CONTAINS A TOTAL OF ABOUT SIX
POINT THREE BILLION IN NEW
THAT IT'S RELATED AND FUNDED
THROUGH THOSE INCREASES IN THE
GUARANTEE. ARE BUT SOME OF THE
FUNDS ALSO REFLECTS A FUNDS THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY USED FOR SOMEONE
TIME ACTIVITIES AYE THAT NOW ARE
AVAILABLE FOR NEW COMMITMENTS AS
PART OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
OF THE TOTAL SIX POINT THREE
BILLION AVAILABLE ARE THE BUDGET
ALLOCATES ABOUT TWO THIRDS TO
NEW ON GOING COMMITMENTS AND
ABOUT ONE THIRD TO ONE TIME
CHARITIES AND INITIATIVES.
TURNING TO PAGE.
FIVE I THINK ADMINISTRATION OUR
TO GIVE YOUR PRETTY GOOD WALK
THROUGH OF WHAT'S IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THE KEY COMPONENTS.
LARGEST ONGOING TWO POINT NINE
BILLION FOR L. CFF OF THE
LARGEST ONE TIME ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION FOR THE ONETIME
DISCRETIONARY GRANTS.
ON.
IN ADDITION THE CT  IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AUGMENTATION
THAT AND YOU'RE COVERING IN
SEPARATE HEARINGS TO ASK THOSE
FOR NOW.
AT PAGE SIX OF OUR HAND OUT IS
JUST A LIST OF ALL THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PROPOSALS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND I'VE REALLY COMPARE ABILITY
ADMINISTRATION SHEET JUST
ORGANIZED A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY.
I TURNING TO PAGE SEVEN IN OUR
ASSESSMENT I THINK OVERALL WHAT
WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS A GOOD MIX OF ONE TIME
AND I'M GOING SPENDING.
I THE IMPORTANCE OF RESERVING
SOME FUNDING FOR ONE TIME
INITIATIVES IS NOT ALWAYS
OBVIOUS AND GOOD ECONOMIC TIMES
LIKE THE STATE IS AND HOW.
BUT IF THE STATE WERE TO
EXPERIENCE A DOWNTURN IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS I THAT APPROACH
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
WOULD HELP THE STATE AVOID THE
NEED FOR REDUCTION STILL CFF FOR
SOME OTHER ONGOING PROGRAM.
I TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF A
PREVIEW OF SOME OF OUR. OTHER
MESSAGES TO HEAR OVER THE NEXT
FEW HEARING THIS.
WE THINK THE ADMINISTRATION I
DESERVE SOME CREDIT FOR IT
IDENTIFYING A GOOD SET OF
PRIORITIES AND THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
THE PROPOSAL'S AIMED AT
EXPANDING CT  ADDRESSING
SPECIALIZED STAFFING SHORTAGES.
ON.
GOT A SUPPORTING LOW PERFORMING
DISTRICT THESE ARE ALL ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN PART OF YOUR
QUITE PRIORITIES FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
I THINK AYE MAIN CONCERN IS THAT
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS I
WOULDN'T ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS IN THOSE
AREAS AND SO IN FOR EACH OF
THOSE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS TO HEAR
US PROVIDE. SOME RECOMMENDED
ALTERNATIVES TO YOU TO CONSIDER
HOW THAT MIGHT TRY TO GET OUT
SOME OF THOSE WHO ISSUE.
ANOTHER CONCERN WE THINK THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RETIRE THE K.
TWELVE MANDATE BACKLOG. THAT
BACKLOG CURRENTLY STANDS AT
AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE THAT
AMOUNT WE ESTIMATE BY LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
WE RECOMMEND YOU IDENTIFY A
FINAL AMOUNT
A FOR THE BACKLOG THAT COULD BE
THE ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES COULD BE A
DIFFERENT AMOUNT.
AND THEN DISTRIBUTE AYE THAT
AMOUNT ON A PER STUDENT BASIS
AB BUT REQUIRE DISTRICTS TO
WRITE OFF ALL OF THEIR REMAINING
CLAIMS AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING THAT FUNDING.
THOUGHT TURNING TO PAGE EIGHT ON
IN THEIR COMMENTS ON THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE OUR OVERALL WE'RE
REALLY NOT THAT DIFFERENT IN OUR
ESTIMATES OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE ACROSS THE PERIOD. ARE
COMPARED WITH OUR NOVEMBER
OUTLOOK ON THAT A TOTAL
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUR ESTIMATES
IN THE BUDGET ESTIMATES ARE
REALLY ONLY ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION ACROSS SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
ATTENDANCE ASSUMPTIONS ARE
REALLY KEY THIS YEAR ESPECIALLY
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WILL BE
LOOKING AT THE AVAILABLE DATA
VERY CLOSELY LIKELY AVAILABLE
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
SEE IF THAT HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONAL APPLY. IF IT DOESN'T
THE EATING NINETEEN GUARANTEE
COULD ACTUALLY DROP A FEW
HUNDRED MILLION. I WILL BE
LOOKING AT THAT CLOSELY AND
KEEPING YOU UPDATED ON THAT
ANALYSIS.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX ESTIMATES AND
THAT'S BEEN A BIT OF A
DIFFERENCE. BETWEEN OUR.
I NUMBERS IN THE PAST
ADMINISTRATION IS A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER THAN WHERE WE WERE IN
NOVEMBER BUT WE THINK OVER ALL.
THEIR NUMBERS ARE REASONABLE IN
A REASONABLE STARTING POINT FOR
YOUR BUDGET DELIBERATIONS.
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
GENERAL FUND REVENUE IS LIKELY
TO BE HIGHER THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES PERHAPS
THREE BILLION OR MORE OVER
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. ABBOTT CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT YOU AYE KRYPTONIAN
MINISTRATION EVEN A REALLY LARGE
INCREASE.
THREE BILLION OR MORE ISN'T
LIKELY TO INCREASE THE GUARANTEE
IN EITHER YEAR ON BY MORE THAN A
FEW HUNDRED MILLION.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
THE AD THAT YOU HAD THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S SAY A FEW
WEEKS AGO. THAT.
OF ANY NEW REVENUE MATERIALIZING
IN MAY MOST OF THAT WILL BE
DISCRETIONARY WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY OF YOUR PRIORITIES.
UNLIKE IN PAST YEARS WHERE IT'S
BEEN DEDICATED A.
SCHOOLS THROUGH PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT.
AS SO WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
SURE I CAN CAN YOU SPENT SOME
MORE TIME THAT THE LAST POINT
THAT YOU JUST MADE AND WHAT
FINANCE SAID EARLIER.
AS FAR AS YOUR YOUR THAT MAC
TAYLOR PROJECTIONS WHAT YOU
CATCHING US NOW IF THERE IF
THERE THREE BILLION HIGHER COME
MAY REVISE.
ALMOST ALL OF IT.
WOULD BE WOULD BE WHEN BE
CALCULATED IN THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEES THAT'S RIGHT SO
ARE AT NOVEMBER.
FISCAL OUTLOOK ESTIMATED THAT
ACROSS SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN STATE REVENUE
WOULD BE THREE POINT TWO BILLION
HIGHER THAN WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOW ACROSS
THOSE TWO YEARS.
A SENSE THAT TIME.
SO FAR THE PRELIMINARY DATA
SUGGESTS
HOW ABOUT SOME INCREASED LOOKS
LIKELY AYE JANUARY TAX
COLLECTIONS FOR EXAMPLE WERE
ALREADY TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION.
HIGHER THAN THAT JANUARY BUDGET
ESTIMATES.
ON HIM WE KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
THE.
RECENT TURBULENCE IN THE STOCK
MARKET SORT OF CHANGES OUR
OUTLOOK.
AND WE DON'T THINK IT DOES AT
THIS POINT AYE EVEN AT ITS
LOWEST POINT OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS.
THE STOCK MARKET IS STILL ABOVE
THE LEVEL THAT WE HAD ASSUMED WE
DID OUR NOVEMBER OUTLOOK.
SO EVEN IF THE MONEY'S COMMAND.
FOR THAT.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR.
AND IT THERE ONE TIME MONIES
THAT WOULD IT GOING TO THAT.
NINETY EIGHT ONE TIME. LEDGER.
SO THAT PREDICT THE GUARANTEE
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN COULD
INCREASE PERHAPS AROUND TWO
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION SOMETHING ALONG THOSE
LINES THAT'S PROBABLY SORT OF
THE BEST CASE FOR THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
AND THAT INCREASE COULD ALSO
CARRY FORWARD INTO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN COULD
BE A FEW HUNDRED MILLION HIGHER.
I THAN WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
ESTIMATES AND IN THAT CASE IT
WAS AN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YOU
WOULD HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
ONGOING MONEY TO WORK WITH.
AND BUT IT'S NOT LIKELY TO BE.
THE DYNAMIC THAT WE HADN'T SAY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WITH A GUARANTEE
WERE STATE REVENUE INCREASED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
GUARANTEE WAS GOING ESSENTIALLY
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR WITHOUT
INCREASE.
OKAY. AND THEN.
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SOME
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ONE. HAD.
YEAH I TO ISSUES THAT WE HAVE.
BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT ARRIVING
HEARING ON I THINK NEXT WEEK IS
A SPECIAL ED AND A FEW WEEKS AGO
WE HAD A HEARING ON. THAT THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE AND SO SEEING
THE PROPOSAL WHERE YOU KIND OF
FAT. MERE THOSE TWO ISSUES WITH
THE.
WITH THE TEACHER RESIDENCY IDEA
HERE WE WE HAD HEARINGS LAST FEW
YEARS AND IN SOME OF THE MOST
PROMISING IDEAS CAME FROM.
THE.
LP I LEARNING POLICY LIGHTS BUT
THE TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAM SO
IT'S BEEN EMBRACED FOR. FOR GOT%
SPECIAL ED. BUT IS IS THERE
ALSO.
AND OPENNESS TO LOOK AT THE
IDEA AS.
THAT EDUCATION AS A WHOLE
BECAUSE WE HAD TO HAVE A TEACHER
SHORTAGE IN.
ALL THE AREAS ACROSS THE BOARD
NOT JUST A SPECIAL AND.
AND THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
UNIQUE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
DISTRICTS HAVE TO PAY UP. THERE
THEIR PIECES WELL AND YOU THINK
AND GROW THEIR OWN SO IT'S BEEN
ABOUT PROMISING ON SEVERAL
FRONTS.
I'M GOING TO DIRECT MY COLLEAGUE
SHE'S OUR EXPERT IN.
HI KIM LADY WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
A FINANCE
SOME DON'T LAST FEW BUDGETS HAVE
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR
A STEM BILINGUAL AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
AND MANY OF THE.
GRANTEES HAVE MOVED FORWARD
WITH.
PROPOSALS AND PROJECTS THAT
WILL EMBRACE STEM AM BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND YET WE WE TEND TO
SEE THAT THERE'S STILL A
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND SO THESE THESE
PROPOSALS ARE FOCUSED.
RIGHT NOW ONLY ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION
I GET THAT BUT WHAT BY WHAT I
ASKED IS. THE DEED THE BROADER
PROPOSALS FOR THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS WHERE. WHERE THERE ARE
ON ON ALL AREAS AND IF REVENUES
WERE AVAILABLE IS THAT IT IS
THE?
?
THIS ADMINISTRATION OPENED IT TO
THESE APPROACHES AS WELL HOW
LAST YEAR WE DIDN'T DO ANY OF
THAT. TEACHER RESIDENCY IDEAS IN
THIS YEAR WE HAVE JUST A NEW
WANTS ONE FOR THIS TOPIC.
BUT BUT OVERALL FOR ALL ALL
SUBJECT AREAS IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU THINK.
.
HAS MERIT.
WELL THAT WILL BE A
CONSIDERATION FOR THE MAY
REVISION.
THANK YOU.
YES I KNOW YOU HAVE TO DO YOUR
JOB JUST LIKE I HAVE TO DO MUCH.
.
THE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR MEDINA.
ON THE.
ONE TIME SPENDING.
THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE THE.
IT'S MILLION.
.
IS THAT A NEW ENTITY OR THAT
EXISTS LAST YEAR.
THE THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
IT'S BEEN IN EXISTENCE HOME.
YEAH YEAH YEAH I BELIEVE IT WAS
AT IMPLEMENT WHEN ELSIE ITSELF
WASN'T THIRTEEN SLANTED EYES
AGAIN IT'S BEEN IN EXISTENCE.
BOTH.
THAT.
ENTITY.
AND THE.
AND THE COUNTIES
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION BOTH.
OVERSEE.
THE SCHOOLS THAT.
I I FORGET THE TERM IT THAT IS
USE DIFFERENT A NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT WHATEVER THE.
THE TERM IS NEEDED
DIFFERENTIATOR FOR IT YET.
RIGHT SO. MY QUESTION IS HOW HOW
ON WHAT BASES.
BUT WHAT IS THE CRITERIA TO TO
DECIDE.
WHAT ENTITY SINCE THEY'RE BOTH?
KIND OF DOING THE SAME THING
CORRECT BOTH THE COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION. AND THIS
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE OF
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE. BOTH
THEIR OVERSEEING SCHOOLS THAT
NEED.
A EXTRA HELP.
ON WHAT BASIS DO YOU DO IS A
DECIDED WHAT ENTITY DOES IT.
EVER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY DISCUSSIONS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER WAY RIGHT
NOW THAT I'M DEPARTMENT IN THE
STATE BOARD HAVE A AN INTERSTATE
MENTAL WORKING GROUP A GLIMPSE
OF WHAT IT'S CALLED I'M THE
CONSISTS OF THE COUNTIES THAT.
STATE FOR THE COLLABORATIVE
DISTRICTS.
SUBPLOTS ARE EVEN INVOLVED AND
REALLY ASK THE STRUCTURE
DEVELOPS WERE WORKING ON
DEFINING THOSE CLEAR ROLES I'M
OUR INTENT IS THAT COUNTIES
WOULD BE THE FIRST LINE OF
CONTACT IN THE CLOCK RATES ROLL
WOULD REALLY BE ON. HELPING TO
BUILD THOSE AT THE CAPACITY AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT ASSISTANCE.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT IN SOME
CASES THAT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES MAY BE.
A LITTLE A LITTLE FRACTURED.
AND SO THERE IS THE OPTION OF
FOR THE COLLABORATIVE TO ALSO
YOU TO STEP IN AND PROVIDE THAT
ASSISTANCE AS WELL BUT REALLY
THE COUNTY OFFICES ARE GONNA BE
THAT. FIRST POINT OF CONTACT.
BUT I LIKE THAT ANSWER BECAUSE
IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY THERE.
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION ARE
ALREADY THERE ALREADY HAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
SO I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT THEY
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION ARE
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER ARTS ITCHING THANK YOU
I'D LIKE TO. ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO.
I I LIKE TO POSE THE SAME
QUESTION BUT OPPOSE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT EARLIER WHICH IS
THAT.
YOU KNOW EVEN IN THESE.
GUY GOOD BUDGET TIMES THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE.
AND PROJECTING.
DEFICITS A YEAR OR TWO OUT WITH
A RAPIDLY INCREASING COSTS
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION PENSIONS
HEALTHCAR COSTS.
WHAT WHAT IS THE YEAR THE END
IN ONE OF THE MOST FREQUENT
COMPLEXITY HERE IS IS THAT? THE
THE BASE GRANT IS INADEQUATE AS
AS PART THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. OF BECAUSE THAT
IS THE ONLY PORTION THAT IF
THERE THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
USED ON THOSE.
RAPIDLY ESCALATING COST
COMPONENTS.
WAY WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ITS POSITION AS TO
THEIR.
VIA.
IT WILL BE APPARENT REALITY THAT
THEY WILL ONE DAY IF IF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE DOES AGREE
THAT IT THAT THERE ARE.
.
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE PROJECTING
DEFICITS A EVEN IN THIS COULD
BUDGET TIED TIMES INTO WHETHER
WE.
WHERE WAY WHAT IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PROPOSED
TO?
WAY WITH THESE THAT WAY WE WENT
WITH THIS CHALLENGE.
TRIP UP AARON IDIOT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND.
I THINK WE WOULD CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FACING
INCREASING COSTS JUST LIKE MANY
OTHER AREAS OF THE BUDGET ARM I
CAN'T SPEAK TO.
V. THAT YOU AS YOU MENTIONED
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WRECKING
DEFICIT STUFF I JUST HAVEN'T I
HAVEN'T SEEN IDEA PERSONALLY.
I THINK OUR RESPONSE THOUGH
WOULD BE.
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THOSE IF
F..
MY COLLEAGUE LISA MENTIONED THAT
SINCE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WE'VE
NOW WITH EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
PROPOSED BUDGET AND HAVE A TOTAL
OF TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS OF NEW
ON GOING MONEY THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND NOT CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO BE
RECEIVING UNDER THE LC FF AND.
AND THAT IS NOT INSIGNIFICANT.
.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE BASS
GRANT TWO VERSES SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION GRANTS I I THINK I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT AS WELL
THAT. STATUTE DOES IT IT'S IT'S
NOT SO MUCH A SPENDING
REQUIREMENT AS A REQUIREMENT TO
INCREASE IMPROVE SERVICES SO
THERE IS SOME.
IT YOU KNOW POTENTIAL FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO.
YOU'D BE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE TO
THEIR EL CAP THROUGH THAT'S YOU
KNOW THAT THE INTENT THROUGH THE
COMEDIAN GAUGE AND PROCESS THAT
PAY HERE'S HOW WE'RE IMPROVING.
SERVICES FOR THE STUDENTS IT
MIGHT BE A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR.
SITUATION IT MIGHT NOT BE I
MEAN THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE KNOW
WHAT THE INTENT WITH LOCAL
CONTROL IS SO THAT THEY CAN LOOK
AT THEIR ALL OF THEIR.
COST PRESSURES WHATEVER THOSE
MIGHT BE AND BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THEM IN A WAY THAT SADDAM.
YOU KNOW NOT HAM STRINGING THEM
AS I THINK WE WE WOULD VIEW THAT
THE PREVIOUS YOU KNOW PRE LCF
HAVE A STRUCTURE IS WHERE THEY
DO JUST HAD.
CATEGORICAL WASN'T SPECIFIC WAYS
THAT THEY WERE YOU KNOW HAD TO.
DIRECT THOSE FUNDS AND NOW THEY
HAVE A LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
BE ABLE TO SAY SIT BACK AND YOU
KNOW BE AT THE BARGAINING TABLE
BE AT THE THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT TABLE FOR THEIR CAPS
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR FOR THEIR
NEEDS
SO IT'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SUGGESTING THAT.
CONCENTRATION AND SUPPLEMENTAL
DOLLARS CAN BE SPENT TO ADDRESS
PENSION COSTS AND. SPECIAL
EDUCATION BECAUSE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD ARGUE
THAT SPECIFICALLY AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT WHEN I
I JUST WOULD POINT OUT AGAIN
THAT IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A
SPENDING REQUIREMENT THAT'S ALL
I WAS ME SAY.
BUT THE SPENDING REQUIREMENT IS
THAT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION DOLLARS GO ONLY
TO.
THE THREE IDENTIFIED CATEGORIES
OF DISADVANTAGED TO AND SINCE SO
I WILL SAY I DON'T ON THE
SHOWRUNNERS UNDERSTAND.
I THINK.
ALL I'M TRYING TO POINT OUT IS
JUST THAT.
YES THE FOR THE FUNDING IS
DERIVED SPECIFICALLY FROM THOSE
STUDENTS BUT THE STATUTE.
DIRECTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO INCREASE OUR
IMPROVE SERVICES AND THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY ALWAYS A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR.
.
EXERCISES ALL I'M TRYING TO SAY.
COULD YOU GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
HEALTH SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION DOLLARS MAY BE
SPENT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE.
CERTAINLY THROW SO ONE EXAMPLE
THAT THAT COMES TO MIND I MEAN
STATUTE IS THERE'S AN EXAMPLE
WHERE I SCHOOL DISTRICT MAY BE
TO HAVE A DISTRICT WIDE.
CHANGE.
ARE OR A PROJECT THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO TO EMBARK ON AND.
WELL YOU COULD SAIL DISTRICT
WIDE OKAY THAT'S GOING TO BE
YOUR YOUR BASE RECORD OF
STUDENTS THAT MAYBE AREN'T ON TO
KEEP PEOPLE'S AND ALSO YOUR
INDICATED PEOPLE'S AS WELL THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE IN AFFECTING
AND. THERE IS SOME LEEWAY WITHIN
THE EL CAP JUST TO TO
DEMONSTRATE OKAY IT'S A DISTRICT
WIDE BENEFIT BUT IT'S ALSO
SPECIFICALLY GOING TO BENEFIT
JUST THOSE UNDEFEATED PEOPLE'S
AS WELL. AND NOTS.
SOMETHING THAT THE STATUTE
GIVES FLEXIBILITY TO LOCALS TO
BE ABLE TO TO DO.
WHETHER WHETHER TAKING FUNDING.
DERIVE FOR THOSE STUDENTS
BUT ALSO FUNDING FROM THE BASIN
AND SAYING OKAY THIS IS A
DISTRICT WIDE BENEFIT IT'S NOT
ONLY.
INCREASING INCREASING IMPROVING
SERVICES FOR ALL YOUR UNDIVIDED
PUPILS AND ALSO FOR YOUR.
KNOWLEDGE.
WELL THAT'S NOT WHAT THE.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE TELLING
ME.
THEIR THEIR AND AND I THINK
THAT THIS IS A GUY OF A REAL
CHALLENGE THAT TO. THE.
.
THEN THAT DISTRICTS ARE FACING
A.
.
YEAH.
OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU AND I GUESS THIS
IS ON. OUR OPENING ACTED SO WILL
CERTAINLY.
BE I WORKING THROUGH THESE FOR
ISSUES FOR THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
AND THEN COME BACK DURING THE
MAY REVISED HAVE.
BROADER DISCUSSION AS FAR AS THE
FINAL ACTION I WITH THAT WE WILL
NOW PROCEED WITH OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT ALLOW INDIVIDUALS AND.
GROUPS TO SHARE THEIR.
REALLY PERSPECTIVE ON THE.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET COULD
RELATE TO PROP. NINETY EIGHT IN
K. TWELVE
.
THANK YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP IT TOO
MINURSO.
GO AHEAD BILL.
YEAH.
YET WHERE YOU'RE GOOD OKAY.
.
GUARDS.
SO TO.
WE
.
THEY'RE ONLY A MEMBER.
WE'RE ACTUALLY.
GATES.
I REGARDED.
KIDS ARE DISADVANTAGED.
NOW.
THIRTY FOUR IS WHEN THE AYE
IF THERE'S.
ASK YOU TO ACTUALLY PLAY THE
SAME.
.
REPEAT THE POSSIBILITY OF.
HAS REVEALED.
ANNUAL.
CARE THOSE WE.
DIDN'T USE HERE.
FOR ANY SPECIFIC REASON
A LONG WAIT AND SEE
PROHIBITED FROM.
AND WE LIVE
SELLERS ARE PRETTY
IT ACTUALLY SHOWS EVIDENCE
FROM THE S..
USE AND CONTINUOUSLY.
BOB HOPE ORDERS.
IS IT PAN.
FOR SOME
STORIES.
ZAPPA CONTRARY.
EARLIER.
RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
BAKER
WE.
AT FIFTY.
SHARES OF CONCERNS ABOUT.
TEST THREE BE CUT THAT HAD
HAPPENED LAST YEAR IN THE STATE
BUDGET AND YOU WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S A POSITIVE PRECEDENT TO
MOVE FORWARD INCOMPLETE CUTTING.
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE AN ECONOMIC RECESSION
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT THAT WE
DID NOT SEE CUTS IN OTHER AREAS
OF THE BUDGET AND WANTED TO
CONTINUALLY REMIND. OUR
COLLEAGUES WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE WE ARE SEEKING A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION OF
MONICA AND SURE THAT IF WE HAVE
ANY TYPE OF BUDGET MISHAPS IN
THE FUTURE. WE WOULDN'T SEE
EDUCATION FUNDING HUNDRED IN
ANYWAY WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT WE HAVE A CERTIFICATION OF
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS SO WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON WHAT ALL THE
FACTS ARE. IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT EDUCATION IS PROPERLY
FUNDED BY WE DO HAVE A FEW.
ISSUES THAT WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO A WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE DEDUCTION OF
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
ONETIME DISCRETIONARY GRANTS
THAT WE ARE SET TO RECEIVE.
AND BECAUSE OF MEDICAL NOT MEDI
CAL BILLING AND WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT TALKING HAVE. REAL
ENCROACHMENT INTO THE OVERALL
FUNDS THAT WE'D BE RECEIVING
WERE ALSO OPPOSED TO.
FUNDING FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS AT
THE INCREASE OF TWENTY EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION IN CHARTER
SCHOOL FUNDING IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF MONEY
TO HAVE SEYMOUR. OVERSIGHT
SCHOOL AUTHORIZATION FISCAL AND
ACCOUNTING TRANSPARENCY FROM
FURTHER.
WE DO AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE AT
YESTERDAY'S HEARING AT BY SOME
REMEMBER MEDINA IN REGARD TO AYE
RE ASKING FOR A POLICY HEARING
ON THE ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BUDGET PROPOSAL WHILE DOESN'T IN
YEAH SPECIFICALLY. INCLUDE K.
TWELVE WE ARE CONCERNED THAT IT
COULD HAVE SOME POLICY
IMPLICATIONS NUMBER ONE ON.
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL IMPLICATIONS BUT
WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED THAT THERE
ARE OTHER STUDENTS THAT COULD
ATTEND WHICH COULD INCLUDE K.
TWELVE TO A ROMAN STUDENTS WHO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
ISSUE IS PROPERLY.
DISCUSS PARTY MOVING FORWARD AND
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE SOME POLICY
CONCERNS ABOUT THE KEY TWELVE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM AND WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OVERSIGHT MINISTRATION BY THE
KING CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SINCE
WE'D LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THAT DISCUSS AN APOLLO BUT
THERE'S MANY ITEMS OF.
PORT ON OUR LADDER.
AND THAT ACTUALLY GETS A
SUPPORTS A FEW THINGS THAT WE'RE
VERY APPRECIATIVE BEGAN
RECOGNIZING THE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WILL TAKE. TO GET
US TO FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AS
WELL AS THE ONE TIME ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS THAT WOULD
GO TO ALL LEDS TO ADDRESS. THE
MYRIAD OF ISSUES THAT WE ALL
FACE INTEREST OF COSTS ON A
PRESSURES AND NEEDS LOCALLY AS
WELL AS THE COLE LEFT FUNDING.
UP ON THE WORK FORCE ISSUES THAT
WERE. DETAILED TO BE DISCUSSED
HERE FOR US IT'S REALLY LOOKING
MORE BEYOND AND REALLY ENSURING
THAT AL ELEAZAR HAVE THE ABILITY
TO HIRE AND RETAIN STAFF NOT
JUST. IN PARTICULAR ROUTE TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION BUT ALL
BRANCHES OF THAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT RECOGNITION. AND ON THE
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SEVENTIES AS
SIX MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
CONTINUOUS SYSTEM THAT WE REALLY
ARE BUILDING IT UP WHERE THE
COUNTY OFFICES CAN PROVIDE ALL
ELLIE IS WITH THE SUPPORT. AND
THAT WE HAVE THE EXPERTISE AT
THIS NEW AT THE CC  SO THAT
THEY CAN GO OUT AND AND PROVIDE
US WITH EXTENDED AN INFORMATION
AND RESOURCES.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CHAI
SURPRISED THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT TWO
AND THIRTY THOUSAND CLASS BY
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES. I WOULD
JUST MAKE A FEW POINTS AT THIS
EARLY STAGE IN YOUR OVERVIEW.
ONE NIGHT DON'T THINK IT'S A HOP
MENTIONED YET THAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT IS A MINIMUM GUARANTEE. SO
I THINK THERE'S NO PROHIBITION
FOR YOU TO BREAK THAT CEILINGS
ON SPEAK IT'S A FLOOR NOT A
CEILING.
NOW THE IDEA IS THAT WE A
PREACHER APPRECIATE ALL THE
INVESTMENT IN HOUSE SCHOOLS OVER
THESE YEARS.
BUT I THINK THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
RECOGNITION OF THE WORK OF THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF.
AND WE WOULD URGE YOU WHAT IS
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION ON OTHER
AREAS OF FIND WAYS TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IF YOU WANT TO EXPAND
SPECIAL EDUCATION OUTREACH FOR
EXAMPLE. THAT CLASSIFY STAFF OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HELP THOSE
CHILDREN ONE ON ONE IF YOU
WANTED TO BE MAINSTREAM. HOW
MEMBERS OF THE ONE TO STAND
BETWEEN DOES HAVE BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS?
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY DON'T
HARM THEMSELVES.
AND SO WE ARE INTO MENTAL AND
DOES BECAUSE A PROGRAM AND WE DO
THINK FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU TALK
ABOUT EQUITY. FOR FOOD IN THE
LCF AFTER DISTILLING NEED A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE NEED FOR
IT ADEQUATE. TRANSPORTATION
ACOSTA ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF SOME
SORT HEY WE WOULD URGE YOU TO
LOOK IN THOSE AREA BECAUSE THE
VERY POOR AREAS. TO RULE MELT IN
THIS AREA YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
KIDS GETTING TO SCHOOLS AND
WOULD LIKE TO PUT DOWN ON THE
TABLE ALSO.
AND FINALLY WE JUST HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ACTING. IN OTHER AREAS
WHENEVER YOU USE PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDS FOR PRIVATE ENTITIES
AND RECENTLY WON A WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPLORE
PARTICULARLY IN THE ONLINE. A
COMMITTEE COLLEGE ISSUE WHEN YOU
GET TO HIGHER EDUCATION. A IS
THE INTENT TO LEAD TO PROVIDE
FUNDING ON THAT WOULD GO TO A
PRIVATE ENTITY AND THAT SIX
SEVENTEEN SOMETHING THAT. WE SAW
IN THE TRAILER BILL BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WHICH OFFICE
ON THE LEGISLATURE. TO EXPLORE
WHAT IT THAT'S THE TO TO INTENT
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE RAISED A FLAG CONSENT AT
THIS STAGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON BRAD STRONG SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN NOW.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY MEMBERS.
I THINK OF COUPLE THINGS FIRST
TIMER.
WE THINK THERE WAS A LETTER
THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED THERE'S
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE INCLUDE CIVIL RIGHTS MENTAL
HEALTH. AND MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FIGHT CRIME
INVEST IN KIDS MISSION READINESS
FALL SUPPORTED.
SCHOOL CLIMATE AND TO
ENGAGEMENT.
PROPOSALS SO THIS THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
CHAMPION IN THE PAST IN TERMS OF
AUGMENTATION FOR PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN. THE FUNDING FOR
MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT.
AND ALSO AND WE'RE ASKING THIS
YEAR ALSO FOR SCHOOL CLIMATE
SERVE SURVEYS INVESTMENTS IN
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS.
THINK THESE THESE ISSUES
ADDRESSED THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDRESS TRAUMA RESTORATIVE
PRACTICES IF WE'RE WORRIED
ABOUT.
HIM THE THE YOU KNOW THE ISSUES
A SCHOOL SHOOTING OR EVEN.
BIHAR SUSPENSIONS AND SCHOOL
CLIMATE THESE THINGS ARE ALL
DIRECTLY RELATED SO IF WE THERE
BUT TWENTY FIVE ORGANIZATIONS WE
HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER THAT.
THOSE AUGMENTATIONS FROM TIME
CHILDREN NOW.
I HAVE A TO HAVE A LETTER THAT
AND COVERED A NUMBER OF ISSUES.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
YOU HEARD EARLIER THE STATE AND
THE GUARANTEE THAT IS IS NOT
LIKELY TO GROW.
WITH THE REVISE AND WE THINK
THAT.
FLUTE THAT THE THE NINETY EIGHT.
SHOULD BE VIEWS AS A FLOOR NOT
A CEILING AND THAT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE.
A OVER APPROPRIATIONS.
IN THE IRWIN WITH THE REVISED.
ON THEM A COUPLE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES. ALSO OBVIOUSLY ALL THE
ONES THAT THAT WERE RAISED IN
MULTI TIERED SYSTEM SUPPORT
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS. FOR THE AND THE
GOVERNOR STE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
WE WOULD WE WOULD URGE WE
SUPPORT THAT FRAMEWORK.
ACTUALLY BELIEVE IT REGIONAL
SUPPORT LEADS NEED GREATER
INVESTMENT THAT YOU'D WANT TO
READ REGIONAL EYES.
SOME SUPPORT STRUCTURES AND WE
WOULD VIRGIN AUGMENTATION.
AND THAT WITHIN THAT. ENGLISH
NAMES ARE TO USE LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT.
FRAMEWORK SO. IN THE PAST DOWN
THIS COMMITTEE HAD INVESTED AND
THE HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE HEALTH
FRAMEWORK IMPLEMENTATION.
SIMILARLY THIS YEAR WE BELIEVE
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS
THE SAME TYPE OF IMPLEMENTATION
EFFORTS FOR IN THIS NAMES ARE
TUNING ASSIGNS DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH ALSO INCLUDES THE. ENERGY
RAPID AT BRYN.
I YOU'LL YOU'LL HAVE YOU GOT A
GREAT LETTER WILL WE'RE READING
IT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LIST KEY AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES.
WE APPRECIATE UMP THE BUDGET
GENERALLY.
THE.
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT.
FOR FULL FUNDING LCF AMP IS
QUITE WELCOME ALSO.
WE KNOW THAT IT'S IT'S NOT
ENOUGH IT'S NOT ADEQUATE.
WE APPRECIATE THE BUDGET
TRAILER BARREL.
INCLUSION OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AS PART OF THE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT WE THINK THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT UNDERPINNING OF THE
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT PROCESS.
AND THAT OF STAKEHOLDERS PARENTS
STUDENTS AND AND STAFF DO NEED
TO BE ENGAGED FOR THIS TO BE
REALLY A LOCAL CONTROL EFFORT.
HOWEVER WE THINK THAT THE AMOUNT
OF PROPOSED FOR SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING OUT
WITH THE CHAIR AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO INCREASE THAT
AMOUNT. WITH REGARD TO THE
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY PROPOSAL A
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT WHERE.
WHERE THE?
BUDGET TRAILER BILL PROPOSES TO
LOCATE IT WE THINK THAT IT
SHOULD BE CENTERED AROUND THE EL
CAP SINCE THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE
DIRECTED.
MOST PEOPLE TO LOOK TO FOR
IMPROVEMENT. A AND.
WE ALSO URGE US ALL TO CONSIDER
WHAT QUESTIONS ARE WE REALLY
TRYING TO ANSWER. ALL AROUND
TRANSPARENCY.
THANK YOU. YOU.
GOOD EVENING CERRILLOS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TEACH CLASS AND OUTS
ONE ECHO SOME OF THE POINTS THAT
AND THE SKIN WAS MAKING ON THE
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY WE DO A
GROUP UP REALLY APPRECIATE THE.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TOOK TO
BEGIN TO TRY TO ADDRESS FINISH
UP TRANSPARENCY WE KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE MANY OF YOU HAVE
BEEN LEADING THE CHARGE FOR SOME
TIME. TAP A ALLOW A COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BETTER
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
TO ASK AND ANSWER MEANINGFUL
QUESTIONS ARE WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE CROSSWALK THE PROPOSED
CROSSWALK. DOESN'T GET US TO
WHERE WE WANT TO BE.
SO WE WOULD URGE YOU THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE MORE
SUBSTANTIVE CONVERSATIONS ASKING
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT TODAY WHAT%
IT WAS INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER HIS
QUESTIONS AND AND WHAT CAN THAT
LOOK LIKE. SO THAT IT MEANS
SOMETHING FOR STAKEHOLDERS.
WE ALSO WANT TO APPROACH. OUR
OUR TEACHERS ONE EXPRESSED
APPRECIATION FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DOLLARS WITH THE
INTENT LANGUAGE TO FOCUS ON
BEGINNING TEACHER SUPPORT
MENTORSHIP.
WE WOULD JUST ASK WE THINK
THAT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
REDUCE TURNOVER TED TO IMPROVE
SUPPORT RETENTION FOR EARLY
CAREER TEACHERS.
WE THINK IT THE.
SHOULD BE I'M GOING IN NOT ONE
TIME FUNDS AND SHOULD REALLY BE
OUT FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE EARLY CREE KERR TEACHERS
HAVE THE TIME SUPPORTING EACH
DEVELOPED. THINKS THAT YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAPIDLY
HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
THERE'S MUCH TO LIKE IN THIS
BUDGET AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
CERTAINLY.
AN INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR LCF
UP TO CLOSE THE FUNDING GAP ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION
DISCRETIONARY DOLLARS.
KING CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO.
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF SLOTS
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD AND AND SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT THAT YOU
PUT FORTH IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
MISTER CHAIR.
HOWEVER WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
BROUGHT THIS UP I THINK YOU
ALLUDED TO THIS IN AS A PROPOSAL
TO ADDRESS THIS. IS INCREASING
THE BASE AMOUNT ON TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND I THINK WE NEED TO
BEGIN TO TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE CLOSING THE
FUNDING GAP FOR LCF OUT DOESN'T
MEAN WE HAVE ENOUGH MONEY IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT SOLVING THE SCHOOL
FUNDING PROBLEM. AND TO BE FORTY
THIRD OR FORTY FIFTH THE FORTY
SIX IN THE COUNTRY IS NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR CALIFORNIA AND
SO ON WHAT WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO IS TAKE
SERIOUSLY INCREASE IN THE BASE
FUNDING FOR DISTRICTS. AND OUT
THANK YOU MURATSUCHI FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT THE TWENTY POINT
THREE MILLION FOR THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES GRANT PROGRAM
WE ACTUALLY. DON'T BELIEVE THAT
NUMBER QUITE GETS US TO.
FULLY FUNDING THE PROGRAM AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ON THAT
AS YOU NOTE.
FACILITIES IS STILL THE MOST
CHRONIC NEED FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
THEY STILL DON'T HAVE
SUFFICIENT
FACILITIES WE THINK THIS PROGRAM
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO.
GETTING THERE AS FAR AS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
WERE ALWAYS OPEN TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT DON'T THINK
THAT THIS PROPOSAL SHOULD BE
REJECTED FOR THOSE REASONS
THANKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
JEFF AKA REPRESENTING RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
DR JUDY Y.. A JUST TWO QUICK
POINTS OF THIS EVENING NUMBER
ONE.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT I
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FULLY
FUND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AND SECOND ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO.
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO PROVIDE.
A DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THERE
COUNTIES AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ON THAT POINT. THANK YOU.
HI SUSAN BONIER I'M HERE
REPRESENTING MISSION READINESS
WHICH IS RETIRED GENERALS AND
ADMIRALS AND FIGHT CRIME INVEST
IN KIDS LAW ENFORCEMENT LEADERS.
I'M A ME TOO ON THE LETTER THAT
WAS HANDED OUT TO YOU.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
DISCIPLINE WITHIN SCHOOLS FOUND
NEEDS A OVERHAUL STATEWIDE AND
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE INCREASE
FUNDING FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
AND POSITIVE BEHAVIOR
INTERVENTIONS.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THOSE
PROBLEMS LAND IN THE LAP OF
TEACHERS AND SO WE THINK THAT
PUTTING MONEY IN A GRANT PROGRAM
SO THAT THERE CAN BE A SYSTEM
WIDE CHANGE WHERE ADMINISTRATORS
ARE ABLE TO REALLY IMPLEMENT.
THE BEST POSSIBLE DISCIPLINE
SOLUTIONS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IS
WHAT WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERS DON'T WANT
TO EVER ENCOUNTER.
THESE KIDS THEY WANT THEM TO
STAY IN SCHOOL AND OUR MILITARY
LEADERS BELIEVE STRONGLY.
IN THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE
BEING SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
HANDLED WITHIN THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM SO WE NEED FUNDING FOR
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND THAT.
RAPS UP INCLUDES TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU
.
THURMOND ILLITERACY.
RIGHT